[Müzik]
Merhaba Hepiniz hoş geldiniz Ben Cem
karikatüristim Geçenlerde bunu birine
söylediğimde karikatüristim dediğimde
bana iyi de gerçekte nesin diye
sordular bu aslında böyle son 12 Senem
sirayet eden bir soruymuş galiba Çünkü
sürekli son nedir özellikle gerçekte
neyim ne yapıyorum diye sorup duruyorum
kendime hikaye de aslında 12 sene
öncesine dayanıyor Eee Yani üniversiteye
başladığım ilk zamanlar karikatür çizmek
istiyorum Bir Güzel Sanatlar
fakültesinde sürekli karikatürleri
dergilere gönderiyorum ama hiçbir
şekilde geri dönüş alamıyorum hiçbir
şekilde iyi ya da kötü Eee ya da ne
bileyim eleştirel herhangi bir şey
göremiyorum çünkü gerçekten
eleştirilecek tarafı falan yok
karikatürlerinin çok kötü bir
karikatüristim çok kötü bir amatör
karikatüristim
Neyse bir ik sene falan sürdü Bu e
amatör karikatürist değim ve sürekli
gönderdim yayınlanmadı gönderdim
yayınlanmadı bu kötü Kariyerim devam
ediyor Daha sonra bir gün bir
şehirlerarası otobüs yolculuğunda E bir
mola yerinde indim işte yine ümitsizce
Dergiye bakıyorum Yeni sayı çıkmış
dergide amatör sayfada kendi karikatürüm
gördüm Çok şaşırdım tabii Çünkü 2
senedir uğraşıyorum her hafta bir aynı
tempoyla çalışmışım gönder şim falan ama
ilk defa 2 sene sonra karikatürüm o sarı
siyah sayfada gördüm ismim falan
yazıyordu benim için çok dramatik bir
andı Aslında sevincimi nasıl
göstereceğimi de
bilemedim direkt şeye döndüm E otobüse
döndüm ama içim içime sığmıyor çok
sevinçliyim sevincimi nasıl anlatacağım
bilmiyorum böyle sürekli arada dergiyi
okşuyorum dergide kendi sayfamı
okşuyorum arada muavine ok atmaya
çalışıyorum muavin Bana kek getiriyor
deli herhalde falan diye kek getiriyor
Biraz kekimi yerken okşuyorum biraz
Dergiye kek yedirmeye çalışıyorum falan
yani bir amatör karikatüre ne
kadar sevilmeyecek o kadar garip
seviniyorum
aslında Neyse bir türlü Aslında şeyi Bu
sevincimi aktarabilmek İki senedir
uğraştığınız bir şey elde etmişsiniz bir
şekilde böyle daha fazlasını
istiyorsunuz daha fazla
eee sevinç gösterisi yapmak istiyorsunuz
o dönemi bilenler hatırlayacaktır böyle
Eee mesajların ya bir mesaja böyle iki
kontör ödediğiniz dönemler Benim de e
100 kontörüm var ve 49 kişi seçtim yani
50 kişiye mesaj atabilirim Çünkü eee
şeyi duyuracağım dergide karikatürüm
yayınlandı falan diye onu
duyuracağım 49 kişiyi seçtim Bir kişiyi
ayırdım o 49 kişiye bir tane hazır mesaj
yazdım dedim ki işte penguen dergisinde
karikatürüm yayınlandı alırsanız
sevinirim İyi günler gibi bir Hazır
mesaj 49 kişiye gönderdim işte yakın
çevrem var arkadaşlarım var birçoğu
sallamadı zaten geri geri dönmediler
işte ya da dönen alırız falan ama
muhtemelen almadı falan ya onlar için o
kadar önemli olmaması Aslında normaldi
benim Çünkü çok hevesle yaptığım bir
şeydi neyse o bir mesajı sakladığım
mesajı ayrı bir mesaj olarak yazdım
çünkü o üniversitede hoşlandığım kızdı
ona öyle Beta bir mesaj yazamazdım işte
karikatürüm çıktı alsana falan filan
yazamazdım ona şey yazdım
ya penguen benim karikatürüm yayınlamış
da istersen
al Neyse cevaplar gelmeye başladı bana
yavaş yavaş işte şey Yazan oluyor işte
aldık abi güzel falan işte annem yazıyor
Çok güzel oğlum Tebrik ederim falan ama
beklediğim mesaj bir türlü gelmiyor Daha
sonra telefonun ışığı yandı ve mesaj
geldi Ben mesajda şöyle bir şey
yazdığını varsayıyorum işte Cem zaten
senin ne kadar zeki ve yetenekli biri
olduğunu biliyordum sana çok inanıyordum
işte Şu an evde bir usta var ve eve bir
strip direği yaptırıyorum ve sana akşam
çok özel bir şov
hazırladım Sonuçta pengen karikatürün
yayınlanmış ve Seninle deli gibi
evlenmek istiyorum gibi mesaj
bekliyordum mesajı açınca öyle
olmadığını fark ettim mesajda şey
yazıyordu dergiyi aldım B gözleri öyle
yapma tar baktım Dergiye ya gözleri öyle
yapmamışım ki yani eleştirme beni bu
kadar sevindiğim bir şeyi aşağıya
çekme sonra otobüs yolculuğuna devam
ediyorum Çünkü o tatsız mesaj gerçekten
tadımı
kaçırabilir sürprizle karşılaştım o gün
bir e İstanbul'a indim Eee Taksim'de eee
bir Şampiyonlar Ligi maçında Fenerbahçe
Chelsea'yi yenmiş
İstiklal bayram yeri Herkes işte
konvoylarda işte meşaleler yanıyor
halaylar çekiliyor
falan dünyanın ilk Kamufle olarak
sevinen insanı olarak Taksim'deyim Çünkü
düşüncem şuydu
Birileri bir şeye
seviniyor Ben de seviniyorum Bunlar
farklı şeyler olabilir Ama niye beraber
sevmeyelim daha sonra ben kendimi
Fenerbahçe taraftarlarıyla araba
sallarken
işte meşale yakarken halay çekerken
falan buldum
beyoğlunda
istiklalde neyse o gün aynı gün içinde
geri dönmem gerekiyordu öğrenci evime
Eskişehir'e Geri döndüğümde meşaleden
biraz Kirpiklerim ve kaşlarım yanmış
Boynumda Kaş kol ve üzerime Biraz içki
çekilmiş dökülmüş şekilde şeye geri
döndüm Eskişehir'e Neyse ben kariyerimi
tabii böyle devam edeceğini varsayıyorum
sürekli Göndermeye devam ediyorum işte
Ama gene o iki senelik O berbat dönem
geri gelmiş gibi hissediyorum çünkü yine
yayınlanmıyor işlerim yine bir geri
dönüş alamıyorum falan E şimdi şey de
geçiyor zamanım da geçiyor işte
Büyüyorum falan bir iki senede öyle
geçti ve Ben 4 sınıfa kadar
geldim
artık bana dediler ki Cem bu karikatür
olaylarını falan artık bırak bence Çünkü
olmuyor 4 sene oldu bir kere karikatürün
yayınlandı kirpiklerini yaktın geldin
yani gerçekten köşe verseler ne
yapacaksın acaba gibi yaklaşımlarda
bulunuyordu iyi dedim ben de yani çünkü
düşünüyorum artık böyle 4 sınıftayım
hayallerimi gerçekleştirmek için çok
fazla zamanım kalmamış gibi hissediyorum
falan bana dediler ki işe gir
Yani herkese söylenildiği gibi bir doğru
dürüst işe gir sigortan yatsın en
azından hani şu karikatür fantezisi
biraz uzaklaş gerçek Hayata
dön Neyse
Eee ben bir post Prodüksiyon şirketiyle
iş görüşmesine gittim Çünkü artık param
da azalıyordu Yani karikatür
gönderebilecek param bile kalmamıştı zor
bir öğrencilik dönemi
oluyordu bu görüşmede bana şey dediler
ya işte eee biz sana para vereceğiz İş
hayatını anlatıyor Adam bana işte biz
sana para vereceğiz Sen bizim
belirlediğimiz saatlerde uyanacaksın
bizim belirlediğimiz saatlerde buraya
geleceksin Ondan sonra bizim
belirlediğimiz bu insanlarla bizim
belirlediğimiz saatlerde yemeğini
yiyeceksin öyle gün içinde çok Telefonla
falan oynamak yok hafta sonunda
belirlediğim saatlerde veya İş olmazsa
çıkarsın
sosyalleşir dedim ki beyefendi Şaka mı
bu ya Çünkü bir nevi ben
beni ben yapan şeyleri istiyorsunuz Bir
nevi özgürlüğümü istiyorsunuz yani Ama
dediler para
veriyoruz Ben de dedim bu nasıl bir Para
parayı söylediler büyük bir paraymış
kabul ettim
işi kabul ettim
ama ya o kadar potansiyelimi
gösterebileceğim bir iş değil ki o kadar
benden uzak bir şey ki bir de kabul
etmem sebebi ya gerçekten çok fazla
paraya ihtiyacımın olduğu bir dönem
olmasıydı Neyse ben çalışmaya devam
ediyorum falan ama gerçekten mutlu
değilim ve gerçekten potansiyelimi
ortaya koyamıyorum Çünkü ben kendi
öykülerimi anlatmak istiyorum Kendi
düşüncelerimi aktarmak istiyorum burada
aslında bir düşüncenin Bir öykünün bir
parçasını yapıyor gibi
hissediyorum Neyse böyle böyle ben
aslında bir buçuk 2 sene kadar çalıştım
ama bir yandan karikatür Göndermeye de
devam ediyorum karikatür Kariyerim aynı
şekilde şekilde hiç olmadığı gibi baş
aşağı gidiyor
Aslında
Neyse ben sonra bir gün şeyde Eee
internette dolaşırken bir görsele
rastladım bu görselde bir yelkendi Bir
Gemi
görseliyle bir kadın
Eee Sözde şu yazıyordu geminin altındaki
Sözde
işte gemiler limanda güvendedir
ama gemiler okyanuslar denizler veya
dalgalar için üretilmiştir gibi bir söz
sonra ben bunu kendi kariyerimle böyle
bir bağdaştırmaya çalıştım gerçekten
çalıştığım post Prodüksiyon şirketinde
inanılmaz güvendeyim batmam imkanı yok
Asla su Almam ama bana gerçekten Öykü
yazdırabilecek veya bu öykülerimi İşte
bu hikayeleri anlatabileceğim bir alan
tanımıyor ama çok güvendeyim maddi
olarak finansal olarak inanılmaz güvende
hissettiğim bir
yer ama gerçekten limandan çıkmak
istiyorum ki bu dalgalarla işte eee
boğuşup Belki de batıp belki de ne
bileyim e gemimin su almasını izleyip
Belki de tamamen batıp O gemiyi
tekrardan inşa etmem gerektiğini de
biliyorum Sonra annemi aradım Dedim ki
Eee anne ben istifa edeceğim dedim yani
Yaptığım işten Annem dedi ki şaka mı bu
yani çok iyi kazanıyorsun iyi bir
kariyer elde ettin devam et işte ne
güzel yok dedim ben yapmak istediğim
şeyi yapmak istiyorum karikatür yapmak
istiyorum Daha sonra işten istifa ettim
ve gerçekten her şey planladığım gibi
gitti batıyorum Yani başka iş
bulamıyorum yine çok az param kaldı ve
yine berbat bir b planıyla
Askere gitmeye karar
verdim Dedim bu askerlik nasıl
oluyor işte bana dediler ki bizim
belirlediğimiz saatlerde
kalkıyorsun bizim belirlediğimiz
saatlerde
işte burada oluyorsun bizim
belirlediğimiz saatlerde bizim
belirlediğimiz bu insanlarla yemek
yiyorsun gibi gibi benzer
şeyler e dedim ki şaka mı bu iş hayatı
gibi yani güzel yapıyordum Zaten ben
bunu askerlik o kadar da zor bir şey
değilmiş gibi
geldi Neyse gittim Hani derler ya
içeride böyle düşünmek için çok fırsatım
oldu falan diye sürekli düşünüyorum ya
ben bu kariyerimle ne yapıyorum B
planlarım çok kötü ve gemim Sürekli
batıp
duruyor Askerde bir de C planı çıkarttım
kendime askerde ameliyat oldum burnumdan
burnumdan ameliyat şekilde askerliğin
bitmesine 19 gün kalmıştı burnumdan
ameliyat olmuş şekilde cebimde hiç para
yokken kafam 3 numara tıraşlı yken
İstanbul'da bir ev tuttum Çok az param
var çok az eşyam var hatta hiç yok
Sadece elimde kalemler işte boyalar
vesair eler ya çok minimal böyle feodal
Japon evleri gibi minimal Evde oturup
sakem mi içebilirim yani bende sadece
Kiler var
yerde daha sonra o elimdekiler bir şey
yapmaya çalıştım bundan önceki taktiğim
hiç bu olmamıştı ilk defa Belki de
Konfor alanından çıkmıştım bundan önce
şöyle çalışıyordum dergi işlerine işte A
bu hafta ne yapılmış şu yapılmış Ben de
böyle bir şey yapayım ha bak bu tutuyor
Ben de böyle bir şey yapayım ilk defa
internetim yok doğalgazım yok doğru
dürüst Kalemim yok vesaire bilgisayarım
yok elimdeki boyalarla işte sulu
boyalarla guaj boyalarla elimde ne
malzeme varsa onlarla
alakalı birkaç çalışma yaptım ama
dergiler o kadar çok
kovulmuştur göze alamıyorum Dergiye
gitmeye
korkuyorum o yüzden dedim ki Ben dedim
derginin içine Sızım buna trua taktiği
adını verdim derginin içine sızma
taktiğim şu editörlerden birinin yeni
kitabı çıkmıştı ona Mail attım abi dedim
kitabım çıkmış hayırlı olsun
işte ben iş göstermeye gelmeyeceğim
merak etme Araya hep onu katıyorum iş
göstermeye gelmeyeceğim merak etme
Sadece kitabı imzalatıp gideceğim İş
göstermeye gelmeyeceğim merak etme sağ
olsun o da davet etti
beni Ama aklımda şu var trua taktiği şu
kitabın arasına kendi o yaptım işleri
koyacağım tam kitabı imzalatır onların
hepsi yere saçıl A bunlar burada mıymış
gibi bir şey ol Bir nevi patronu
ayartmaya çalışan sekreter hareketi
yapacağım
yeni ameliyatlı ve Kafanız 3 numaray Ken
çok böyle doğru düşünemiyorsun Ama ben
bu taktikle Bir nevi içeriye sızdım
diyebilirim ama kitap şöyle
olmuştu 100 120 sayfalık bir kitaptı ben
işleri koyduktan sonra böyle Suç ve Ceza
gibi bir şey oldu böyle iki
cilt Neyse ben Dergiye girdim işte
E editöre şey diyorum sürekli abi mesel
işine devam Zaten ben iş göstermeyeceğim
falan hani mail'de de belirtmiştim zaten
falan sürekli böyle histerik gibi ble
sürekli şey iş göstermeyeceğim iş
göstermeyeceğim böle Çünkü kovulmak
istemiyorum Neyse ben dedim abi kitabı
imzal atayım sana gideyim hani çok
zamanını almayayım ama kitabı
çıkartamıyorum çantam laım Çünkü kitap
gerçekten iki cilt Neyse kitabı
çıkarttım gerçekten planım tıkır tıkır
işliyor Tam açtım abi Şurayı imzalar
mısın diye hepsi yere saçıldı ve
istediğim reaksiyonu aldım bunlar ne
dedim ki Aa Bunlar burada mı kalmış
300 tane
karikatür neyse ne bunlar ya falan dedi
ya dedim çok önemli şeyler değil yani
öyle ben kendi kendime yapıyordum araya
karışmış Siz de dedim hani isterseniz
bakın İyi bakalım falan dedi O sırada
diğer editör girdi odaya Ne yapıyorsunuz
siz burada ya dedi adam normal olarak
Çünkü yerde 300 tane böyle yere saçılmış
karikatür var ha işte Cem bunları yapmış
falan filan dediler ve beraber bakmaya
başladılar ondan sonra bana dediler ki E
işte Güzelmiş Bunlar işte niye bunu bize
köşe olarak yapmıyorsun ki falan dediler
Ben direkt sallanacak araba arıyorum
sevincimi
Çünkü meşale arıyorum kirpiklerimi
yakmak
istiyorum sonra şeyi sordular ik soru
olarak bunu her haa hafta yapabilecek
misin sanki ben 10 senedir her hafta
yapmıyormuş gibi her hafta yapabilecek
misin dediler dedim ki abi Şaka mı bu
yani ben zaten bunu 10 senedir her hafta
yapabiliyorum O gün bugündür o gün bana
köşeyi verdiler
Eee Yaklaşık 5 senelik bir periyot bu
onun içine işte sergiler ü tane kitap
işte binlerce karikatür bazıları yere
saçılmış olanlardan bazıları yenilerden
bir sürü Eee iş sığdı
hiç
böyle gidemeyeceğim yerlere gitmiş oldum
bu iş sayesinde hiç belki de böyle
tanışacağımı düşünmediğim insanlarla
tanıştım y ilk defa Aslında bir
nevi şeyi gemiyi limandan çıkartıp bir
şeylerin riskini göze almamın sonucunda
bir şey elde etmiş oldum Evet bu süreçte
gemimi Fareler bastı mı Evet battım mı
yelkenlerim delindi mi hepsini yaşadım
hepsi gerçekten kötü tecrübeler
ama beni Aslında bir nevi buraya getiren
şey gemimi limandan çıkartmam
dı daha sonra bazen arada Kendime
soruyorum ya diyorum Gerçekte ben neyim
yani ne yapıyorum Aslında Hani
karikatüristim de gerçekte neyim ne
yapıyorum gibi
şeyleri ve Bunları düşününce Gerçekten
hayal ettiğim şeyi yapan biri
olarak buluyorum kendimi ve bu bence
Aslında insanın kendi kendine Armağan
edebileceği en büyük şey ve arada böyle
yaptığım şeyleri tanıştığım insanları
gezdiğim yerleri gördükçe de kendi
kendime Şaka mı bu diye soruyorum ama
şunu çok iyi biliyorum ki dünya zaten
başlı başına kocaman bir şaka
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
teşekkürler